here's the fun question we introduced
nck me you know even wrote it like this
with no respect to of revenging stuff
where did we meet nck the first time
when CR it was with Pascal triangle and
then why was it useful to us what kind
of question we're trying to answer it
was it was the coefficient of something
like this now this is um i'm gonna get
settle my nerves i need the space this
is worth writing down as sort of like a
subscript to this something like this
write that for me okay now what is this
mean what does this mean okay now
because we know the binomial theorem you
guys can just expand this without even
thinking okay but just realize what is
your twitter and i've alluded to this
already when we were at wing that
probability earlier right what this
really means is actually and write this
out longhand with me give me a favor
that's what this means okay now think of
that how you would have done this before
you knew about proper fancy expansions
in that kind of me right all you could
do is just multiply across right that's
that's what this means so for instance
like every time you ultimately cuz there
by Toby you have to choose one or the
other mainly you multiply all the way
through so let's be simple balance right
I'm going to use I'm going to avoid
index notation because it actually
disguises something attacking you i'm
going to go a and a first-half at that
that's going to be one of the terms that
i get out of this extension right it's
just one of them for reasons that it
become clear in a second and we go to
the next line um that's not the only one
I could have say a and then be hmm how
did I change like the middle one right
how about a and then B and then a like
that and how about if I choose to be
first why not write B and then a
and like that see you see these this is
all the ways that I could just have one
of the bees picked out does that make
sense okay there's a few more right how
many ways can I do how many ways can I
arrange these terms if I just chose to
bees instead of 28 let's go look exactly
the same as this belong to swap the A's
and B's right I could choose B than v10
hey I could choose B then a then B and
then I could choose a then B then B and
then the only option I've got left the
only one I haven't done because this is
all the only way you can get 3 a's see
these are the only ways you can have 28
this is the only these the only ways you
can have one a and then there's one way
left that you can have no ends right see
what I've done and of course we're like
who's got time to write that so then we
go to the binomial expansion which is
this guy but have a look at what's sorry
and what's different between when I
actually wrote the expansion out and
what I've written here what's the
difference between this and there's what
is lost when I condense all of these
guys into this what's lost the order
right because what we've done is we have
treated all of these guys we've just put
them all in a pile instead you're all
the same there's three of you right so
it's like I don't care which way where
the big is I don't care where the a is
you're all the same to me you're all
just a pile right and so we say okay
sure tell me how big the pilots does
that make sense okay so binomial theorem
all this time has been arranging objects
it's just a big objects that have been
arranged are the two terms in your
binomial okay does that make sense that
is why like we came to this by thinking
about blocks right but few blocks and
these are just 30 blocks that's all okay
so turning through 10g they just use
these principles or ever get in lots of
different combinations okay the only
thing I haven't mentioned is almost
stuff because I'm going to take you in
for the phone the only thing I had an
engine is when they put additional
restrictions on you for instance how
many ways are there to arrange these ten
let's get these repeats out of the way
how many ways are there to arrange these
ten if the black and white say that they
have to sit together they have to sit
together okay now this is really cool
because you can think about the same
principles the same principles and how
to arrange these guys right if the black
and white ones have to sit together
together then you're not placing Ted
objects anymore are you you're actually
placing nine when you see ya later look
here you go there are my nine objects
okay and I'm like all right well the
first one I have I have 92 strong and
then I've got eight and then eventually
I get an order right so that was 9
factorial ways but you have undercounted
haven't you right because you know those
two you could just say hey wheres
nedick's to jar but i'm just going to
swap places there's still next to each
other so what I did was how we come up
with this number the 9 factorial where'd
it come from think when it come from it
came from I had nine boxes to fill and
then you multiply by 2 factorial because
because these guys they they themselves
they're very little arrangement and
there are two boxes to feel it again
where they are does that make sense so
so this is why this is why like I kept
not asking about what is that number
there and what is that number wise that
number like these guys are both on the
denominator offer completely different
reasons and these guys are multiplied
together I mean obviously this
is are the same cup qualification
doesn't care about order but they're
there for different reasons does that
make sense you see how to produce